now as he traveled to Normandy this
morning president Trump blamed Democrats
in Mexico for the growing number of
migrants illegally crossing the southern
border last month the US border agents
made more than 132,000 apprehensions the
highest monthly level since 2006 that
amounts to about 4,000 people a day the
president plans to respond with tariffs
on all Mexican goods despite opposition
from his own party and others and a lot
of people senators included they have no
idea what they're talking about when it
comes to Paris
Mexico's foreign minister is in
Washington for negotiations we Jiujiang
is at the White House we Joe where did
the talks with Mexico stand right now oh
good morning Dana President Trump says
the US and Mexico teams are making
progress but quote not nearly enough to
prevent the tariffs today talks will
continue after secretary Pompeo vice
president pence and other administration
officials met with the Mexican
delegation here at the White House
yesterday
afterwards mexico's foreign minister
marcelo abroad said immigration was the
main focus of that conversation not
tariffs he's optimistic they will reach
a deal to stop them but if the two sides
don't agree on a solution five percent
tariffs on all Mexican goods will go
into effect on Monday and Klein by five
percent until they hit 25 percent in
October many Republicans have expressed
opposition to the plan and concerns that
American consumers will pay for it the
auto industry would take the toughest
hit and car prices could soar by over a
thousand dollars Mexico is our biggest
trading partner so everything from
electronics to beer to fruits and
vegetables will cost more Congress could
try to block the tariffs and actually
earlier this week Republicans warned the
White House they may have enough votes
to override a presidential veto Tony we
J thank you very much